what's popping Morty it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is a breakdown of episode 5 of
season 7 of Rick and Morty that featured
the showdown between Ricks that we've
all been waiting for with a very
unlikely oneeyed assist from Evil Morty
so let's break down this Multiverse
Madness together gang and the episode
starts with a Morty covered in the ass
juice of an unidentified alien as juice
that is soon revealed to be the Catalyst
for the origins of evil Morty a
character that we last Saw way back in
season 5 episode 10's Rick marai Jack
that ended with evil Morty tearing a
hole in the central finite curve to free
himself from a Multiverse of arrogant
Ricks but anyways after Rick yells at
Morty for complaining about being forced
inside of an alien anus for the
millionth time Morty absolutely snaps
and intentionally gets Rick drunk in
order to distract him while he went
upstairs to make his new high-tech
cybernetic eye patch A high-tech eye ey
patch with the ability to control evil
Mor's Grandpa as well as to scan a
person's brain waves and predict their
next move as we see evil Morty do during
his fight with Rick Prime towards the
end of the episode and while Morty is
sitting at his desk making this eye
patch you can see hilarious movie
posters on his wall for a film called
Satan's devil and another poster for a
horror film called mollusk Maneater with
a picture of a man cowering in fear in
front of a giant mollusk can be seen
next to the tagline just try to run I
would pay a crazy amount of money just
to see this movie not even going to lie
but anyways when Morty gets back to the
garage in order to convert his grandpa
into his cybernetic slave you can see
that Rick has consumed an insane amount
of alcohol in that time 14 bottles five
cans and two whiskey bottles worth of
alcohol to be exact and while I was
counting all of those loose bottles I
could not help but notice a variant of
Mega Man's Mega Buster on the shelf in
the garage of this universe with this
Mega Buster being great gray with two
yellow bars instead of blue with one
yellow bar like Mega Man Has and after
Morty hijacks Rick's body we can see
evil Morty head to the Morty Agency on
the Citadel of Ricks located of course
not too far away from Morty insurance
down the road and when they head inside
and walk past the front desk you can see
Rick and Morty brochures with the title
A ge's the perfect fit and a calendar
that says Mort implying that this Morty
agency has dedicated an entire month to
Morty during that time and as evil Morty
goes through the Morty directory to
erase all the Intel that the Citadel had
on him from their databases you can see
that the picture that the Citadel used
for evil Morty is frowning with an
uncaring look on his face seemingly
implying that this evil Morty has been
pretty fed up with his adventures with
his Rick for a long while before he
finally snapped then after this we see
evil Morty's perspective from when evil
Morty and his Rick's slave portal to the
universe where they k kill a Rick and
kidnap a Morty just like we first saw
during the opening of season 1 episode
10's close Rec counters of the Rick kind
but speaking of that episode Not only
was that the episode where we were first
introduced to evil Morty in the series
but it is also the episode where we
learned that there was a variant of Rick
called The Scientist formerly known as
Rick who was themed after the famous pop
artist Prince and was murdered by a
mysterious entity before learning that
it was evil Morty pulling the strings
all along by the end of the episode in
this new episode of Rick and Morty we
finally get to see just how the
scientist formerly known as Rick was
killed when evil Morty and evil Rick
portal into the purple dining room of
the family formerly known as The Smiths
and interrupt their spaghetti night with
interdimensional murder and later on in
that evil Morty origin Montage we
learned that evil Morty was inspired to
run for president at the Citadel after
finding a newspaper in a trash can
outside of a Morty Mar convenience door
stocked with alcohol conveniently
located next to a bar with a neon sign
with Rick's favorite XX beer on it trace
ays and later after the title drop we
catch up with evil Morty as he makes his
way through a treacherous landscape of
crystals and monsters with a large pink
crystal in hand a crystal that I believe
to be crystallized xanthine also known
as th crystals which are the same
crystals that Rick uses to access images
of the Multiverse through
interdimensional cable and while running
through all of that chaos Morty rushes
past several parodies of the Jetson's
family before a couple of variants of
this futuristic family get
instantaneously murdered by the Mayhem
of the strange area of the cosmos and it
seems like evil Morty went through that
whole ordeal just so he could find a
pink time Crystal big enough to turn his
entire space home Dome into a giant
interdimensional cable screen that can
project any scene throughout the
Multiverse that Morty desires as he
continues to live his life outside of
the central finite curve for those of
you who do not know the central finite
curve in the Rick and Morty series is
the section of the overall Multiverse
that comprises of every universe that
has a rick who has become the smartest
person of that Universe neatly grouped
together in an organized curve by the
former Council of Ricks before they were
all murdered by evil Morty this being
the case as soon as evil Morty learned
of the existence of the bundling of
universes filled with the most elite
versions of his abusive Grandpa evil
Morty made it his mission to escape all
of those universes of the central finite
curve so he can finally live in
realities free of Ricks but anyways when
evil Morty's Paradise is interrupted by
Rick's attempts to draw out his mortal
enemy Rick Prime from his hiding place
in the Multiverse we can see Rick and
Morty replacing energy cells modeled
after duracel D batteries and when evil
Morty arrives on the scene he references
the famous pickle Rick episode of Rick
and Morty when asking Rick if he should
be turning himself into a pickle instead
of fracking the Multiverse after Rick
Morty and Evil Vil Morty gets sucked
into a surprise prison located inside of
a rick Prime decoy filled with a black
goo similar to that of Venoms from the
Marvel Comics the gang runs into a spy
Rick parody of James Bond a hippie Rick
with a heart necklace that contains a
picture of his dead wife Rick seemingly
modeled after John mlan from the Die
Hard movies a nerdy looking Rick in a
sweater vest a rick with the design
similar to that of John Constantine from
the recent TV show and an Indiana Jones
Rick who pops in last guns of blazing
then later after Rick Prime initiates
his Hunger Games Squid game style battle
arena inside of his prison he reveals
the capabilities of his Omega device
which he has previously used to
eliminate every single variant of Rick's
wife across the Multiverse which is an
extremely Savage thing to do a device
that I believe was meant to be a parody
of both the ultimate nullifier from the
Fantastic 4 Comics as well as the
retroactive Cannon weapon from the comic
book time variance Authority in Marvel
Comics and later when Rick and the Gang
Escape their fiery demise Rick uses a
little bit of that black goo that
swallowed them up to find Rick Prime's
new secret layer very much modeled after
the death star from Star Wars some of
that black goo can even be seen on the
portal that brick makes when he starts
to head on over there Rick even
complains a little bit that Rick Prime
built that installation again much like
Emperor Palpatine built the Death Star
twice in the original Star Wars trilogy
but anyways when all three of them go to
confront Rick Prime Rick Prime
sacrifices the beloved time slowing
wizard slow Mobius who first made his
appearance all the way in season 1
episode 11 as one of Rick's guests
during Summer's house party and while
this was for sure devastating for both
versions of Rick we learned in the
post-credit scene that Rick Prime's
Omega divice would end up leading two
confused and grieving widowers into
fighting each other and falling in love
once again a mini story that I believe
to be in service to the overall idea of
Rick Prime's chaotic nature being the
source of new and happy Beginnings for
other people much like how Rick Prime
killing Diane is literally what has
given our version of Rick the life that
he has now and all of his loved ones in
his life something that Rick struggles
to fully accept while being stuck in his
thousand yard stair while look on down
from the bridge plays in the background
just like it did for a traumatized Morty
in season 1 episode 6's Rick Potion
Number n but anyways when Rick shoots at
Rick Prime to avenge slow Mobius Rick
Prime lifts his hands to stop his
bullets just like Neo does in The Matrix
movies and when evil Morty goes to
attack Rick Prime while scanning him
with his ey patch the ey patch predicts
Rick Prime's quad Rick form which is a
reference to the mutant character quad
from the original Total Recall movie and
finally right before evil Morty hands
Rick Prime over to our main Rick we
learned that Rick Prime called the
schematics for his Omega device booger
AIDS V2 which is a random ass name for
such a devastating weapon but hey Rick
Prime was a random ass guy with was
being the key word here for he is now a
series of hard to clean stains on Rick's
lab coat now and good riddens too [__]
that guy if someone killed my wife I'd
be just as mad as Rick but I am super
curious to see how Rick moves on from
killing his arch nemesis now especially
after spending so many years of his life
solely on trying to track this guy down
and killing him I wonder if Rick is
feeling like he has no purpose for
living anymore and maybe that was evil
Morty's goal all along to have this Rick
actually achieve his goal of killing
Rick Prime just so he could feel empty
inside and potentially even un alive
himself basically evil Morty's way of
killing this Rick slowly but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter or Instagram
or wherever I am on the social medias
but most importantly don't forget to
follow heavy spoilers here on YouTube
because you don't want to miss anything
that we upload and be sure to give this
video a like if you liked it it really
helps out the channel but yeah thank you
guys again for watching this video I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
you guys later goodbye